Paul at four was a huge success who
would have guessed Bethesda announced
today that the game shipped 12 million
copies worldwide for launch day alone
quote representing sales in excess of
750 million dollars in addition the game
is generating quote record sales at
brick-and-mortar stores across Xbox Live
playstation network and also on PC but
those it did not say how many of those
12 million copies shipped to retailers
were actually sold through to consumers
the 750 million dollar number likely
represents the total possible revenue if
indeed all 12 million copies were
actually sold we've contacted Bethesda
for more exact numbers on how followed
for is selling major retailers have
informed Bethesda of a tremendous
consumer interest in fallout 4 with some
noting it was the most pre-ordered game
of the year Bethesda added noting that
the pip-boy edition became the
fastest-selling collector's edition for
any game in history following the
release bethesda was advised that launch
day sales at some of the leading retail
chains were the largest of any game
released this year the company explained
the feza is now shipping more fallout 4
units to retailers to meet ongoing
market demand by comparison the last
game from Bethesda 2011 the Elder
Scrolls 5 skyrim ships 7 million copies
in 48 hours to retailers and sold
through 3.5 million to consumers during
that period fallout 4 was the top played
game it launched at one time reaching
over 470,000 concurrent players this
blasted passive previous record held by
Grand Theft Auto 5 in addition Bethesda
claims the follow-up hit-boy app was the
number one game on the iTunes App Store
finally Bethesda said fallout 4 set a
new record to become the most viewed
game watch for any new game released so
far this year now excuse me while I go
play some fallout 4
you